the VHS look has been popular lately in
music videos another video art as the
90s come back into fashion all neon
colors and diagonal lines and
over-enthusiastic voices I cannot keep
that up now some producers will actually
take the time to get their nice crisp HD
footage and put it to an actual video
recorder to get that effect but let's be
honest most won't most will use the same
filter as everyone else so I figured to
explain how it works I would talk to the
guy who wrote that filter VHS has very
muted color because more information is
dedicated to the the black and white
information or that the luminance part
of the the image the caller suffers a
little bit so it gets down sampled
there's less information there it tends
to kind of get softened and bleed
outside of the edges and stuff when we
originally gathered footage so they went
out to Goodwill and secondhand stores
and picked up as many VHS and s VHS
decks that they could find with the
decks and camcorders that we had we used
a clean reference image that we could
later compare the recorded version on
the deck to so when you take original
clean version and the post VHS version
and line them on top of each other you
can create what we call a lookup table
which allows us to define the color
differences between the two images but a
lot of the times people are quite young
applying these retro filters or styles
and have sort of an idea of what they're
supposed to look like so it's a little
bit of both VHS is an analog format it's
not storing ones and zeros it's storing
patterns on a magnetic tape and that
means that copies aren't a bit perfect
not only is that random noise but
there's also some interesting log
glitches we start with a blank tape
looks like this when you throw it into
one of the VCR decks one of them has the
lid off of it and and that is the one
that actually died making the VHS
transitions that one went through a lot
and all of that got printed onto this
tape essentially just taking the device
and then
and do a lot of bad things to it while
the tape is loaded in through the
playback heads you can run a magnet
across them and really that's up how
it's going to play that back and
tracking be damned
it'll flutter and it'll be all over the
place this one I believe died based on a
belt failure but that belt failed while
I was using two pencil erasers that were
taped to my fingers slowing down the
head while dropping a magnet on top of
it it was interesting and and then all
of a sudden that it just mechanically
stopped the hardest part about that was
just getting a tape out there is a
section in the code that is just called
take damage there are things like what
we call the pop lines when you are
recording tape and you get pieces of
dust or debris or whatever stuck to the
tape and it rolls across the scan head
that one line will just create like a
streak across the screen and then
there's also a scrolling wrinkle
generally it's repeating because often
that happens when the tape jams up or
something like that you end up with the
bunch of wrinkles that somebody then
reassembled the tape back of course
there are some things that a filter
can't add like camera angles neon
typography and fake enthusiasm but
perhaps some things are better left in
the past and there's more from Tom at
the same time next week
coming up later Captain disillusion is
going around in circles but next a
program chosen for you by the algorithm